nevada highway patrol honoring fallen
trooper micah may with a memorial run
this morning here is some video of the
run which just got underway up at the
west gate may as you'll remember died
last month while trying to stop a
carjacker on i-15 cadets from the nevada
department of public safety law
enforcement academy as you see there are
running from the westgate down to the
welcome to las vegas sign and they're
wearing memorial t-shirts in trooper
may's memory the injured police officers
fund will sell those shirts to raise
money for trooper may and his family 5
51 yesterday another event to honor
trooper may in his life and his service
the injured police officers fund teamed
up with nevada highway patrol to hold a
donation drive to support the trooper's
family this is over at nevada coin mart
at jones and flamingo
both organizations are helping mae's
wife and children during this very
difficult time
joanna has been extremely grateful
micah's widow
i've had direct communication with her
and she is such a strong person she's
going through such a hard time she has
two babies at home but she
wants to be strong for them and she's so
grateful that the community has been
stepping up
community certainly has stepped up you
can still donate to help the may family
through the injured police officers fund
we have a link and some information on
that at eight newsnow dot com